when one of your first jobs is sharing
the screen with the world's favorite
webslinger you're bound to be a star
pton list career has only gone up from
there and her transformation is truly
stunning pton Li started her career as a
child model but transitioned to acting
at a very early age that was seemingly
always part of the plan with list
admitting in a conversation with Brook
Shields for interview magazine that
she'd always been eyeing a performing
career and it was thanks to her mother
that the actor got an opportunity to
pursue her dream she said I never
thought of it as a career it started off
as an after school thing I would do
growing up in New York list said that
her twin brother Spencer was approached
first by local producers and that her
mother lobbied hard to get her seen as
well she recalled my mom said oh well my
daughter is the one who's always wanted
to do it and she kind of fought for me
so my mom is really the one that saw
that I could do it list would initially
model in Publications like American Girl
and Justice eventually appearing on
screen in several uncredited roles one
of those uncredited gigs came in 2002
via a spot in the daytime soap opera As
the World Turns should go on to book
rolls in dozens of other film and
television projects before finally
entering the Miyagi verse if you spend a
few minutes scrolling through pton list
filmography you'll find a genuinely
impressive list of titles but if you go
back all the way to the beginning of the
actor's career you might be shocked to
see Liz followed her one-off spots on As
the World Turns with a brief role in one
of the biggest Blockbusters of the early
odd Sam Ry Spider-Man 2 yes L role in
the film is very much of the uncredited
source with the actor appearing
alongside her twin brother as a young
girl chasing a ball through the perilous
streets of New York City the brief scene
comes early in the action when Peter
Parker puts a make or break piece of
delivery on hold to save the young girl
and her brother from being hit by a
truck in terms of screen time the scene
is little more than a cameo for the baby
face list twins but they do earn a line
of dialogue hey you guys no playe in the
streets yes Mr Spiderman brief as it is
the moment remains a memorable one in
what is arguably the best Spider-Man
movie to date and even at such a young
age pton List's boundless Charisma is
well on display like many other young
and upcoming actors list had the
opportunity to play a younger version of
a bigname actor and as it happens she
have quite a bit of success booking such
roles in the first decade of her career
portraying the younger version of some
major Stars over that period one of the
earliest of those roles found list
playing the pre-teen version of
Katherine hagel's Jane Nichols in the
2008 romcom 27 Dresses it remains argu
the biggest of such roles for list not
only because 27 Dresses was a massive
hit at the box office but because the
young actor was front and center as
young Jane throughout the film's opening
flashback two years later she appeared
in The Sorcerer's Apprentice portraying
young Becky Barnes to her Elder onscreen
counterpart Teresa Palmer should follow
that gig by playing the child version of
Teran Mannings Lissa Welsh in a 2011
episode of Law and Order Special Victims
Unit and the very same year list turned
up and credited as a younger version of
Kate Hudson's Dary in something borrowed
as it was 2011 served as a bit of a
breakthrough year for pton list in film
she appeared as Holly Hills in the
Beloved Diary of a Wimpy Kid franchise
adapted from The Works of Jeff Kenny
said franchise began in Earnest a year
prior with the big screen adaptation of
Diary of a Wimpy Kid the first sequel
Diary of a Wimpy Kid Rodrick Rules
followed in 2011 with li kindhearted
Holly becoming a main player in the
action after protagonist Greg hefley
develops a major crush on her though
Holly and Greg were on very friendly
terms by the film's end that Crush goes
largely unrequited in Rodrick Rules
things however heat up between the pair
and the 2012 follow-up Diary of a Wimpy
Kid Dog Days list sees a major jump in
screen time during the sumers set Three
core with Holly and Greg becoming a
full-blown couple by the time the
credits roll in case there was any
question their journey to coupledom is
as hilarious as it is heartwarming and
list is an absolute joy to watch
throughout circling back to 2011 it
turns out that was also the year pton
list landed what was then the biggest
role of her career fronting the Disney
Channel hit Jesse Lista didn't book the
title role in the series instead
appearing as Emma Ross the somewhat
ditsy and fashionable eldest child of
the family Jesse Prescott cares for as
the actor said in an interview with pop
sugar although there was some
differences between her and the
character she played on Jesse the two
share a love for fashion list reprised
her role as Emma for the 2015 Jesse
spin-off bunked and also appeared in
other Disney shows Austin and Ally Casey
Undercover and I didn't do it guest
appearances aside LZ played Emma for
four full seasons of Jesse but as big a
break as a role was the actor admitted
to covor in 2017 that she struggled with
the fact that the general public tends
to hold teen Disney stars to an almost
impossible real world standard she said
it's weird because Disney stars are
normal teenagers everyone expects that
because they have this show where
everything is perfect bad things do
happen obviously but I think they just
expect them to be really conservative
and always cover up and not really be
who they Tru are look I can't really
chat right now because I've got some
holes in my memory to fill hey well
that's why I'm here I can I can totally
help you fill your
holes excuse me perhaps in an effort to
show who she really is after completing
the 2016 Disney movie the swap Les put
considerable effort into distancing
herself from a squeaky clean Disney
image during a 2021 chat with interview
magazine she admitted that was tough in
part because she spent so much time
making rounds of Disney Channel Fair she
forgotten how to audition and ultimately
needed to Rel learn how to keep calm
during the process nevertheless Liz
found herself busy during her post
Disney career quickly Landing the lead
in the independent film anthem of a
Teenage Prophet the Indie drama which
co-starred Shameless breakout Cameron
Monahan and yellow jacket star Juliet
Lewis was a heavier project that
showcased her range Beyond
family-friendly Disney offerings list
has continued to surprise audiences
since including with her role as Tori
and Cobra Kai in a funny twist according
to L comments to wwd her Disney pass
helped her land the Cobra KY roll as the
creators of the Netflix hit apparently
couldn't pass up the opportunity to cast
a former Disney princess in one of the
series most emotionally complex roles
that Gumball is officially paid off big
time for everyone involved though she's
undoubtedly best known as an actor at
this point in her career L spent much of
her pre- Cobra Kai time carving out a
secondary career in the music industry
while she'd been writing songs for years
prior Liss waited until she was 20 to
drop her first single 2018s breakup
Anthem Liar Liar as she told nylon in an
interview coinciding with the release
she'd been holding off recording the
song for a while because it took me a
while to feel super confident and super
proud of it she said she also wanted to
wait until her Disney days were behind
her before pivoting to music as she
didn't want to be filed in with every
other Disney star turned pop singer list
was probably wise to wait as she's been
able to work on her music completely on
her own terms and without Disneys siiz
expectations she has however only
released a handful of singles and music
videos to date and with no new tracks
since 2019 one can only assume her
booming acting career is leaving little
time for the recording studio these days
thanks to her role on COBRA Kai pton
list is a name well respected in
Hollywood circles today but even if her
name now conjures images of a talented
child star transitioning to an adult
career it's worth noting that she's not
the only Paton list in town in fact one
could easily argue the other Pon list
has had every bit as compelling a career
to date with that older actor booking
notable roles in Madmen The Flash Gotham
and the rookie over the years it's
pretty rare that two actors Forge ahead
with the exact same name as sagra rules
tend to limit such issues it's even
rarer that two actors with the same name
of the sort of success the pon lists
have had and yes it's almost unheard of
that the two might end up on the same
call sheet for any film or television
project yet that's precisely what
happened in a 2002 episode of As the
World Turns in which the two patons
apparently appeared not just in the same
episode but the same scene the two pton
Les join the screen again together when
both actors were credited for voice
performances in the 2019 animated
superhero hit Batman hush take care of
your
boss he's not my boss sadly the two do
not share any scenes in hush with the
Elder list giving voice to the nefarious
Poison Ivy and the younger voicing the
butt kicking Barbara Gordon AKA Batgirl
the film was adapted from a popular 2002
story arc from DC Comics that found the
titular baddy using his shocking wealth
of knowledge about man Tariq havoc on
the man behind the mask and his allies
hush debuted at the 2019 San Diego
Comic-Con the day before its streaming
release and remains one of the best
loved of the recent Batman animated
features as for the younger list she
obviously is not fronting the action
here but her badir does play a prival
role in The overarching Narrative and
given how strong list is in the role one
has to wonder why she's done so little
Voice work in the years since list
booked a kobak Kai rooll the year before
Batman H was released but given that a
season 2 day debut as Tory Nichols came
in the series was still part of the
YouTube premium slate of original
programming it's not entirely shocking
list landed the raw as she had already
starred in a pair of Original films for
the then developing streaming service
those films were 2016's the thinning and
this 2018 sequel the thinning New World
Order the young adult dramas are a sort
of hybrid between the Hunger Games and
the perch and folding in a not too
distant future in which overcrowding has
led Society to take Extreme Measures in
population control in this case that
means straight up executing any and
every student who fails to pass a
certain standardized test the films find
lists sharing the screen with the
controversy cting Logan Paul with their
characters discovering and settling
discrepancies in the Fateful test and
eventually uncovering the Gastly
government conspiracy behind the process
the thinning films are hardly aspiring
to high art but the audience scores for
both the original and its sequel are
decent enough so they might be worth a
look if you hot to do a deep dive on
List's pre- Cobra Kai career then came
cob Rai the role of Tory Nichols has
given pton list an opportunity to
showcase her star power at the actor
told scream rant in 2020 she continues
to have a lot of fun with the character
in what she deems a dream job she said
it is the most fun role I've ever had
the chance to play and every day I'm
just like how did I get this and how am
I here I love this so much that Joy
clearly comes across as list embodies
every fuss of the character's physical
and emotional Journey with disarming
Grace playing tooy has also given list
an opportunity to develop legit Mar art
skills which she reportedly refines
during workouts at a small private Dojo
owned by the uncle of a friend the actor
has said as well that she finds her
Cobra Kai role empowering as it forces
her to train so heavily and any Cobra
Kai fan can attest that list puts those
skills to extraordinary use drawing
scenes that require her to speak with a
fist come on now my sister always
promised to take care of me she taught
you better yeah she taught me to
recognize a low class leech but the
actor is arguably at her best on kobra
Kai when she's speaking with her voice
and considering her origin as a child
model and Disney Channel star and L
transformation into a fully developed
karate antagonist has proven quite an
unexpected if most welcome surprise
[Music]
indeed